hi i'm tom with pine biotech and today
we're going to review using our ftp
service with the t-bioinfo platform
first we'll connect to the server using
the ip address and username and password
provided
in the email when you were introduced to
the platform
so we'll connect and uh afterward we'll
be able to go into our uploads folder
and take the large files that we don't
want to repeatedly transfer
and upload them to the ftp
so i'm going to grab the
smallest one i think
and just start that i'm not going to
necessarily let it finish
but once this is uploaded it'll be in a
path
that we can access
through
here
so we'll have
the standard bit export data users ftp
that's always going to be there
then your email address which used to
log in
the folders that you uploaded the file
to
and
the name of the file itself
so we'll save that into a text document
either one or all together or however
many we like
the ends in the extension.svl
it allows the server to know where your
files are and
reference them
without having to upload the entire file
now that we have uploaded our data we
can go into the platform
choose the section we want to upload it
into
and create our
pipeline now we need to upload that data
i'm going to choose
the svl file which is only three
kilobytes instead of these gigantic
one plus two plus gigabyte files
and click start upload
if i have a reference genome i would
upload it in the upload references
section i can also use an svl for that
but i don't have one at the moment
and then click run pipeline
and that's it the data has been uploaded
and run using simply an svl file with
data we've uploaded over ftp
thanks for your time